it's so funny this stuff we teach we
give these thumb rules of thumb these
processes these ways of measuring things
don't buy a house where your payments
more than 1/4 of your take-home pay on a
15-year fixed-rate mortgage put down as
much as you can put down and it's better
if you put down 20% cuz you avoid PMI
these are rules of thumb I've said like
a bazillion freaking times card and
don't own vehicles more than half your
annual income even if they're all paid
for
because vehicles go down in value
anything with a stinkin motor and it
goes down in value and if you have all
your net worth tied up in freakin toys
you're a little boy a little girl and
you're always gonna be a broke little
boy and little girl that's what's going
on and I like cars - I drove a really
nice one down here today you know so I'm
not against you have a nice car against
your nice car haven't you and so I use
these guidelines and I in Farah bleah
this stuff when people get plugged in to
this you know what we teach they're like
I'm gonna do everything you say but
maybe not that one thing I'm like doing
Dave ish stuff I'm gonna do your plan
ish well why don't you just do your plan
and admit that that's what it is and
don't blame me for your stupidity okay
or you get super hardcore financial
Pharisee and make it even harder than
what we lay out and take a lady like
that and just rip her to shreds in some
private Facebook group or something you
know and and that's not my plan either
that's not Dave ish why don't you just
call it your plan you don't agree with
that plan yeah it's okay if you want to
have your plan that's fine mine is the
one that five million people have used
to get out of debt but you can have your
plan but don't blame my plan on your
financial Pharisee self or on your ish
because your ish is when people have but
do stuff and when you have but do stuff
you get a half but result you really do
it's not any different than that you've
got to decide what is the truth and the
problem is our culture has stopped
believing that there is a truth and let
me just help you with this 100%
of you liberals or conservatives that
jump off a building
you will find the sidewalk a hundred
percent of the time you can't fly
there's a thing called the law of
gravity and that is the truth if you
think truth is relative try that
exercise the Darwin Awards will be
awarded to you seriously try that
actually there is a truth one plus one
equals two 100% of the time it's not
relative you don't get to make up your
own plan you don't get to decide that
suddenly payday lending is smart for the
poor it's not it's screwing the poor
it's oppressing the poor if you own a
payday lending operation you are scum if
you walk in there you are dumb if you
defend them you are scum they oppress
and beat up on poor people poor people
need to have access to capital they
don't need to get screwed it keeps them
poor that's the truth it's not really
relative there's not another side to
that equation except the wrong side you
can just look at this stuff car leasing
100% of the time is stupid
mathematically it's a calculator thing
people there's a truth that's
independent of your little relative ish
but so quit being ish decide to be
somebody either I hate everything I
stand for and go off and prove me wrong
or do the stuff we're talking about this
is the Dave Ramsey show